[Music]  where i grew up  it's another world from this one my  father was stuck in time a little bit  what was he like he was religious  just differently like superstitious  something y'all done around these parts  we're going up for my daddy  they don't get many visitors up in those  [Music]  houses  where am i you was in the plane accident  what about my family  baby you wanna only one sound  i need an ambulance ain't no hospital  within 50 miles of here  where you think you is new york said it  this it stands for you  whatever happens to it happens  to you i'm gonna fix you  i'm gonna fix you good  [Music]  all right now tell us what you see  [Applause]  you may live in the city dude but you  for nestle  i got big plans for you  controlling everyone  what's up put you down  this is for your good  [Music]  foreign